[Applause]
strange roles around you Flo across the
room your touch is made of something
Heaven can't hold a candle
to You're Made Of something new let's
not get
complicated let's just enjoy the view
it's hard to be a human so much to put
an answer
[Music]
to but that's just what we do God only
knows where this could go and even if I
love starts to grow out of control you
me go up in
FL Heaven won't be the same I believe I
believe I could die in your K KN doesn't
get doesn't get better than
this God only knows where this could go
and even if my love starts to grow out
of control and you and me go up in
flame Heaven won't be the same God only
knows where this could go and even if my
love starts to go out of control and you
and me
up
FL Heaven won't be the
same welcome to the show everybody give
it up for my crazy gra man y'all
so I love that song I've listened to
that song so much that was Heaven by my
friend NY horn it was released last year
I believe but he he showed us we were
still working on the voice and he showed
us this song like just tiny snippet like
I mean seconds and I was like no wait
what and then I was like and and I loved
it so much and it stayed in my head I
just think it's my favorite song he's
such a great songwriter but it's my
favorite song He's released I love it so
much you should go check out his album
[Music]
anyway
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home